So we can take all of that
in just turn it into an MDP.
I think it's pretty straightforward
to think how you'd turn this kind of
story management system into
a market decision process, right.
So what are states?
Well, we said that last time.
States are just partial trajectories or
partial plot sequences.
Actions, well, they're the story
actions that the system can take.
Your model is still the same model
that we're using before except it's
a player model that means you know.
We've seen a sequence of states.
Or we've seen these trajectories.
Some action is being taken, and
I want to know what plot state
we're likely to be in, given that
the player is doing something.
So it still looks just
like a transition model.
And then the rewards mean
exactly what they meant before,
except here they're
actually standing in for
some notion of what some writer of
a story thinks of as a good story.
>> And you can somehow formalize that so
that you can plan?
>> Yeah, well, you could, but
that gets us to a whole other discussion
about where rewards come from,
which is probably a discussion
that we should have someday.
So maybe we'll do that
towards the end of the class.
But just imagine the right now you
have the reward function the same way
that you would with any other MDP and
you're really worry about where
it comes from it's just there.
>> Okay and
given that these trajectories, or sorry,
the states are now these
full trajectories.
It seems like that makes some things
harder because now there could be
a lot of them but on the other hand you
can never go back to a state you've
been in before so it's acyclic.
So you can actually solve it
more efficiently because you
don't have to run, I mean basically
one value iteration and you're done.
>> Well, that's actually kind
of neat that you said that.
Because I was about to say that
there are two problems with this.
The first problem is, well,
now that you don't have states, but
you have sequences of states,
that's a lot of new states.
How big do you think that is?
>> I'm going to say very.
>> It is very, very big.
In fact, we can be even
more quantitative in that.
It's actually, hyper exponential.
It's like 2 to the 2 to the f.
>> Where,
in terms of the length of the sequence?
>> Yes, of all possible sequences
you can have the number of states.
>> Even.
Okay, yes, yes.
Okay, all right.
>> Because the number of states
is sort of in factorial and
all the different kind of that
we can have but we don't.
All the states don't have
to actually be there and so
at the end of the day it ends up looking
something like 2 to the 2, you know.
And be really really really big.
So the space that we're looking over of
all possible trajectories where things
might be there things might not be there
gets really really big very quickly.
So that's one point that you said.
But on the other hand it turns out that
there's structure there that we're going
to be able to take advantage of.
And, in fact, that's what we do and
why we're bothering to introduce this
formalism that I mentioned earlier.
So let's do that.
Actually before we do that,
let me mention one other
problem with thinking about things
as Markov Decision Processes.
And it's going to be a problem with the
strength of a Markov Decision Process.
So what is the goal of reinforcement
was the goal of solving an MDP?
>> Maximize reward.
>> You maximize reward.
So, in fact, it turns out that if you
take this sort of notion of storytelling
and how I can get someone to do a choose
your own adventure and I've got rewards.
I've got some evaluation
of what best stories are.
What's going to happen?
What is the system going
to learn how to do?
>> Make the author happy?
>> Make the author happy.
That's exactly right,
but not necessarily.
Make the player happy.
>> So what ends up happening
with Markov Decision Processes,
using sort of modeling as Markov
Decision Processes in the obvious way,
is that you force the player
to experience the best story.
No matter what the player does.
No matter whatever choices
you're trying to make.
Nope, this system is
going to make certain
that you're going to enjoy yourself.
Dammit, and
enjoying yourself means whatever
the author thinks is enjoying yourself.
>> So like grad school.
>> It's just like grad school.
>> No, no, no, that's not right.
Why is that a problem
because the the author.
I mean in a book that is
certainly what happens.
The author gets to choose
what you can experience.
>> And that's a good argument, but
if we're bothered with this whole
kind of interactive entertainment,
choose your own adventure story, then if
you don't really have any choice in what
you do, then it's not really
a choose your own adventure story.
>> Got it.
>> The basic idea here,
is because there is a reward, and
because all the algorithms we've ever
thought about with
Markov Decision Processes are about
maximizing long term award
that it's finding an answer.
It's going to find an answer
that's going to force you
down a particular path.
But it turns out we can relax that
need to find the best answer and
actually end up solving hyperextend
is a problem at the same time.
So, let's do that.